JELENA PJESIVAC-GRBOVIC:
So the challenges
Wouter's team faces are not
exclusive to one exclusive.
Capturing data from
different sources,
performing various kinds of
analysis for different clients,
ensuring that the data
analysis is accurate, timely,
and useful, this is common
challenge across the companies.
GCP offers many solutions that
can help you tame this problem
and get the right set of
insights for your business.
So let's dive in.
When people say Google, first
instinct is to think of Search.
And with our original mission
to organize the world's
information and make it
universally accessible,
Google had to solve
many technical problems
to be able to reach--
to build a service that can
serve billions of people.
Many of these
technical challenges
were necessary for search,
but they're actually
general purpose big
data challenges.
So we had to solve
storage problem.
We had the different
types of data,
and we needed different
storage solutions for them--
file systems, databases,
key value stores, et cetera.
We needed to process this
data, and some of this data
needed to be processed as a
batch or as a streaming, right?
Like they have
different tradeoffs.
And finally, we needed to figure
out how to serve our service.
How can we deploy an
update running service
with no downtime?
So over the time, our
infrastructure evolved
and our business evolved.
So now we have, I
think, eight services
that have a daily reach
more than a billion users.
And with this growth, our
technical infrastructure
evolved as well.
And we are now able to support
very different use cases.
Yet all of these use cases still
share the same infrastructure,
hardware, networking,
and software stack.
In the last 15 years,
we've published
about our infrastructure
and the tools
we've built, starting with GFS
and MapReduce papers, Bigtable
Dremel, all the
way to DataPoint,
TensorFlow in the
last few years.
We've actually changed
our Google infrastructure,
but also influenced
the industry.
Now, many of these products have
evolved into cloud offerings
and unlocking this
infrastructure
to our external customers.
We have a variety of products in
compute, storage and databases
space, big data, and
machine learning.
And in the next few slides,
I'll highlight the few that
are relevant to Wouter's case.
So microservices, as you
heard, give you flexibility
to solve one problem at a time.
They're easier to
develop, test, and deploy.
That makes them popular choice.
However, maintaining
microservices
is not a trivial job.
You need to be able to
scale them, upgrade them
without downtime, and figure
out when things go wrong.
So this is where
Google Container Engine
comes to the plate.
Container Engine provides
a fully managed container
solution and allows
you to deploy
your containerized workflows.
So we get a powerful Cluster
Manager and orchestration
system that is built on top
of open source Kubernetes.
It has a private
Container Registry,
so you have your
own microservices
well-defined and hidden.
Convenient and
powerful declarative
API for resource specification.
And because it's built
on Kubernetes, which
is open source, and there
are many other partners
and companies out there
who are using this,
it actually allows you to
combine both public cloud
and on-premise solutions.
So using something
like Container Engine
and Kubernetes, you can
have a hybrid cloud.
The data warehousing is a
huge part of every business.
And SQL is the interface
of choice to this dataset.
In Google Cloud Platform,
if you have datasets up
to 10 terabytes, you can
use Google Cloud SQL.
With it, you get a fully
managed and reliable SQL service
built on Postgres or MySQL that
comes with automatic failover,
and optionally, high
availability mode.
You do not have to
upgrade your database.
monitor it all the time.
We ensure that nothing
happens to your machine,
and the things just run.
It's a performance
and scalable up
to 10 terabytes, 25,000
IOPS, and it comes
with automatic encryption.
And you have full control
over firewall settings
and you can protect your
access to the database.
Being MySQL and Postgres, it
has a strong partner ecosystem.
If your dataset grows to
more than 10 terabytes
and you still want to use SQL,
we do have solution for that.
And it's Google Cloud BigQuery.
BigQuery is the fully
managed, low cost
serverless data warehouse.
You never see the machines.
You just go to the website
and enter your queries.
It exposes SQL interface.
It has a seamless scalability
from gigabytes to petabytes.
And it's secure and reliable.
Again, automatic encryption,
automatic replication.
All of this happens
behind the curtains.
You don't see it.
You just use the service.
However, even with BigQuery
scale and performance,
there are problems
that require sort
of guaranteeing low latency and
consistent throughput, which
is hard to guarantee
with a SQL service.
So for these cases, we
have Google Cloud Bigtable.
This is a NoSQL
big data database
that powers many of the
products you probably use--
Search, Analytics, Maps, Gmail.
It's behind all of that.
It's, again, fully
managed NoSQL database.
You don't get to see
the machines, again,
for all practical purposes.
It has petascale scalability
with very low latency.
And it can grow the
throughput as needed.
The interesting
thing with Bigtable
is, depending on
your access patterns,
it learns and adjusts to them.
So over the time, your serving
becomes more efficient.
So we looked at some of
the storage solutions.
Now you have this data.
You want to process it.
Many of you are coming from
existing frameworks that
may have been built
on open source tools,
like Apache Hadoop or Spark.
We want you to be able
to reuse these tools
in your applications, so we
have a Google Cloud Dataproc
offering.
And this is stateless--
Dataproc gives you
stateless clusters
that can spin up in
seconds, up to a minute.
And can read and write the
data to various sources,
like GCS, Bigtable,
BigQuery, with HDFS and HBASE
compatible connectors.
It also provides convenient
API for management
of both clusters and jobs.
So with Dataproc, you
can choose whether you
want to run your
Dataproc cluster
as a long-living cluster
with HDFS and everything
in it on it, like
you did on-premise
or on other cloud provider.
Or you can take a
benefit of a low latency
that we have for
starting clusters
and run a job per
cluster, and just
bring down the cluster
when your job is done.
So Dataproc is great, but
we learned a few things
in data processing in Google.
So petabyte-scale
processing engine Google way
is our Cloud Dataflow.
The Dataflow took many
of the internal learnings
and turned them into
a data processing
solution that scales both for
batch and streaming workloads.
It is fully managed and
[INAUDIBLE] configured.
You can start Dataflow jobs
with not specifying anything
much than code.
And it provides unified batch
and stream processing model.
So you write your data
transformations once,
and depending on input source
and output source that you use,
we have a streaming pipeline
or we have a batch pipeline.
So if you're consuming
Pub/Sub, voila,
you are having streaming.
If you're consuming GCS,
you are reading the batch.
And we open sourced
the Dataflow SDK
and turned it into Apache
Beam project in the last year.
So we scale to petabytes
of data, millions of QPS
automatically.
And we invested a lot of time
in high quality integrations
with GCP.
Oops.
Google Cloud Platform
ensures seamless integration
of these powerful tools.
You can use any one of them
and be perfectly happy.
But the real power
of the platform
comes from using them
together and providing
comprehensive
solution that's well
integrated with monitoring,
debugging, alerting,
and all these other things.
And this is where GCP excels.
So with this, let's go back
to Business Intelligence case.
WOUTER CUYPERS: Thank you,
Jelena, for the great overview.
So we ended with this slide.
So it's a quick recap
of where we want to go.
I'm going to start with
our original architecture,
like I encountered in
2013 when I started,
and how it still lives.
So we have a monolithic .Net
application on top over SQL
cluster.
And for reporting purposes,
we copy the data every night
to a separate reporting
database so that the analysts
don't bring down production.
That's pretty obvious.
Most of the analysis happens in
Excel using queries that they
write directly on the database.
And then me and Alex,
my tech lead, came in,
and we started to push most
of our really large datasets
into the cloud, into BigQuery.
Mostly this is email.
We send about 2
million emails per day
and we have about five rows of
data, potentially, per email,
so that's quite a lot of rows.
Click tracking also up to 20
million rows on a single day.
SQL couldn't manage that,
but BigQuery does it fine.
We also copy production
data through Cloud Storage
into BigQuery so that our
analysts can enrich the data
that they get from these streams
with the data from production.
Of course, with
one day of delay.
We have adopted
Tableau as the new tool
to analyze data as a
replacement to Excel.
And it's bringing the data that
we have in SQL and in BigQuery
to pretty much everyone in
the company through very nice
looking dashboards.
So we're already
quite data driven.
Lastly, personalization
is also a part of my team.
It's what our data
scientists do.
And they run it in PySpark
on top of Cloud Dataproc.
So we are using the
stateless version
of what Jelena explained.
We provision.
We spin up a cluster.
At night, we do
our calculations,
which import data from
Cloud Storage and BigQuery.
And the results go back
into Cloud Storage.
And then we copy it
back over to production.
This is a big pain point,
because we generate
a lot of data out of Spark.
This can be, really,
millions of rows.
And the copying takes
quite a long time.
So this is a really
big pain point.
To the new architecture,
then, because that's
why you're here for.
The new architecture will
be angular front ends on top
of .Net core microservices
running in containerized Linux
environment in Kubernetes.
All of them have their
own MongoDB database.
So NoSQL, or in some
cases, Cloud SQL.
I'm not going to
go into much detail
about Kubernetes and containers,
because I'm like the BI guy.
But if you have
any questions, feel
free to come up after the show.
This is a very basic back office
screen like we have it today.
I hope you can read
it, I'm not sure.
But what this shows
is for employees
inside one of those
deals that we have,
all of the products, their
name, price, stock information,
how many orders we've had
so far, how many views
we had so that they
can have some kind
of an indication of conversion.
And they use this to
intervene in live sales.
Now, to make this screen
in our new environment,
the UI will have to contact
four different microservices
and BigQuery.
It's going to be
horribly complicated.
So my team said, look,
we will just provide you
with a microservice
which gives all of that
data as a single JSON
payload, and we'll
figure out where to get the
data and how to merge it.
So how do we get the data?
Microservices, obviously,
they talk to each other.
They use direct endpoint calls,
but also asynchronous events.
So let's say you have
a member service.
A new member registers.
It's sent an event and some
kind of other service which
is responsible for sending
out our welcome mail
says, hey, new member,
I'm going to send a mail
without needing a direct call.
Now, we require all
of our microservices
to send out events
for the entities
that they manage internally,
being it a product, an article,
a member, an order.
And each time these things
get created or modified,
we send events
over Cloud Pub/Sub.
And all of those events
are read by Dataflow,
and stored in the Cloud
Bigtable so that my team's BI
environment has a
perfect copy of what is
happening in the microservices.
How do we do that in practice?
We use Google protocol
buffers, which
is a very nice technology for
making these kinds of events.
So you define them as a schema.
And from that schema, you
generate the serialization code
in most common
programming languages.
And they end up being
serialized in very small,
very efficient binary files,
which go over to Pub/Sub bus,
are read by our
streaming Dataflow,
and we just store them
in Bigtable as binary.
So no deserialization
happens in this flow.
It's actually a
very simple flow.
Bigtable is really nice,
because as Jelena said,
you can reach very high
throughput, very low
latency, which is what we need.
Because we are going to
be firing a lot of events.
And a nice feature
as well is that when
you write a cell into
BigQuery, it's timestamped.
And every older version
of that cell is kept.
So we not only have a copy of
our microservice environment,
but we also know the entire
history of everything
that ever happens.
So all of the email address
changes that users did,
changes to orders,
modifications to addresses,
all of those things are kept.
We can roll things back and we
can replay history if we want.
How do we bring the data back?
Bigtable is not for reporting.
It's a key value store.
So we use our own microservices
written in Python or Google Go
to read the data out
of Bigtable and serve
it to back office screens, other
microservices where needed.
The really large data
streams, as before,
go straight into BigQuery.
It doesn't make sense to
fire those into Bigtable.
So we've got our data
in MongoDB, Cloud SQL.
We've got our external
data in BigQuery.
What we want in the end is
analyst data and production
data.
So the production data is to
do things like that back office
screen that I showed you.
And analyst data is the raw
entity data-- all of our users,
all of our orders,
all of our returns.
But also, that preprocessed
data that we were talking about.
So the turnover we did
on a sale last year
and unique visitors we had.
So how do we do that?
How do we use the
intermediate technologies,
like Pub/Sub, Dataflow,
and Bigtable to get there?
Well, it depends a
bit on the scenario,
but we see like four
patterns or strategies
that we use in
combination to get there.
So one of them, I have two real
time strategies and two batch
mode strategies.
The first real time strategy is
to read from different Pub/Subs
at the same time, combining
the data in Dataflow,
and bring that to Bigtable.
An example, we get
new users in everyday,
but our analysts don't
just want to know
how many new users we have.
They also want to know,
where did they come from
and what kind of
device did they use?
The member service will send
us an event about the new user,
but that doesn't contain
that information.
That they need from
the clickstream,
which is another Pub/Sub stream.
So we read both.
We combine the
data, and we store
that final output in Bigtable.
We need to do it like
that, because when we're
reading the
clickstream, we can't
assume that the member entity
will already be in Bigtable.
Another strategy is to
read data from Pub/Sub,
process it in Cloud Dataflow,
and load site information
from Bigtable.
For example, when you want to
calculate the unique visitors
per country, our
clickstream tells us
that who is clicking
where, but it
doesn't tell us what the
country of that user is.
So we ask Bigtable to
tell us the country.
We generate our KPI, and
we store it in Bigtable.
So that's the second
strategy that I
will demonstrate at the
end if I have enough time.
That screen that
we talked about,
that back office screen,
will actually already
be a combination
of both strategies
to make that possible.
Then batch mode.
Here we will read data,
mostly from BigQuery, also
from Bigtable.
We combine it, calculate
it in Cloud Dataflow,
and the end result goes
back into Cloud Bigtable.
If we do a lot of processing
for various kinds of reports,
things that people often
need, that the analysts needs
pre-calculated, that will
be mostly this example.
For example, an email
campaign report.
That's a lot of email click
data that comes from BigQuery.
It's enriched because
this data is pretty bare,
the email tracking data.
Enriched with
member information,
and the results
go into Bigtable.
And that's before the
data science stuff goes
into stateless Cloud Dataproc.
But instead of reading
from SQL, as we do today,
we read from Cloud Bigtable.
And the results also go
back to Cloud Bigtable
so that we can very
fastly provision
this data into production
without needing to copy it over
again to an SQL server
as we did before.
Where the data ends up in the
end depends on who needs it.
If we need it in the back
office or in production,
we serve it through
a microservice
and the data
resides in Bigtable.
If our analysts need it, we
create a dataset in Bigtable,
and depending on the frequency
required-- hourly, daily,
weekly--
we use a Dataflow to stream
this data into BigQuery or Cloud
SQL.
Well, both, actually,
so that people
can join the stuff in BigQuery
with these huge datasets.
Because the really
large datasets,
like our clickstream
and email stream,
we will just enrich
them with Bigtable data
and store the result in BigQuery
as really large, denormalized
datasets.
What if things go wrong?
And they do, and they will.
We back up all of our events.
So all of the events are
also read from Pub/Sub
by a dedicated backup
streaming dataflow, which
stores all of them, again,
as binary into BigQuery.
There's an additional
batch job which copies
it to cold storage
just in case somebody
wants to delete the
table in BigQuery.
Restoring happens by using
the same dataflows, streaming
or batch, doesn't
matter, a streaming
can be run as batch too.
And we change the input from
originally Pub/Sub to BigQuery,
which contains exactly the same
binary protocol buffer files.
And we store the
corrected information
again in Cloud Bigtable.
So now for the demo.
Do we have time?
Yes, we have time.
So this is a very
simple dataflow
that I've built specifically
for showing it here
to demonstrate a little
bit of what we are doing.
So it's on our actual production
data today, because all of what
I've been explaining to
you, it's not done yet.
We're building it.
But we've, of course,
tested a lot of these things
conceptually.
So I'm going to write
our current production
data as event sources
over Cloud Pub/Sub.
I'm going to count them,
but from the clickstream,
I don't know the
country, so I'm going
to get the country
from Bigtable.
And I'm going to store the
result as a time series,
again, in Cloud Bigtable.
And I will use a simple
Node.js bare bones web service
to show that on
the browser screen.
Let's have a look.
Can I switch to the computer?
Oh, yeah.
So when you load your
dataflow in Dataflow,
in the interface and
the [INAUDIBLE] online,
you get a very nice overview in
blocks of what your pipeline is
actually doing.
So it starts with
reading from Pub/Sub.
It's windowing it, in this
case, in one minute windows.
We do some internal
conversion to a clause
that we can use in Java.
We filter it.
And then we count the views.
And within that, we first get
that country from Bigtable.
And now we count
the actual views.
That gets converted into
a mutation, which is then
finally committed to Bigtable.
An the interface is really nice.
You can see how many
workers are doing the job.
Can you actually read that?
Yes, [INAUDIBLE].
You can shake logs,
look for exceptions
if anything is going wrong.
It's a really nice interface.
Now, Pub/Sub, I can't
show you much about that.
But what I can show
you is Stackdriver,
which shows us how many
events are coming in.
So currently, we have
a good 100 events
per second going through--
well, going through
the Pub/Sub channel.
If I show you that per day,
you see the typical morning
and evening peak
that our website has.
So we're seeing events.
Now, what kind of
events are those?
This is our website.
Let's say I'm
interested in shoes.
I'm actually doing
this over a phone,
because the wi-fi wouldn't
cooperate, so bear with me.
So I'm going to
show a few products.
Put one in my cart.
Now, with BigQuery,
they look like this.
I'm going to refresh this.
BigQuery is really nice
for these furry details.
So this is a table of probably
a good 10 million rows now.
It has some setup
time in the beginning,
because your query
gets dispatched
over x amount of machines, and
then the results come back.
So it takes a few seconds.
But then it goes very quickly.
So you see here I have a product
fuse I would like updated.
I've devised identifiers,
session identifiers.
This is that user identifier
that I will be using.
And we also stored some
additional unstructured data
in JSON, mostly
to optimize things
like recommender
engines and such things.
So finally, what is
this going to look like?
I can't show you
much of Bigtable,
but this is how it looks if you
talk to it using your command
line interface.
So I'm going to get
the last few events.
And here you see my time series.
Oh, can you read that?
Here you see my time series.
So you see events, the page
views for Belgium, Luxembourg,
and Netherlands being
written per minute.
And with a timestamp.
So you see when the data was
being written into Bigtable.
So this is how it looks like.
So you see my one
minute time series
that was generated by Dataflow.
And to show you the real
real-timeness of the thing,
I've instructed Dataflow
to update my latest
window every few seconds.
So these are the actual events
as coming on our website
right now.
It's not fake.
And voila!
This gives you an
idea of how you
can use Cloud Dataflow to
use these kinds of things.
So back to Jelena.
OK, can I go back to the slides?
OK, thank you, Wouter.
So to summarize,
today we've seen
and explored Vente-Exclusive's
business intelligence use case.
We looked at the GCP products
that make this use case easier
to manage.
And we've also seen
a pretty cool demo.
I'm still baffled that we are
looking at the production data.
Like it's neat.
We hope that you will
recognize similarities
with problems that you're facing
and problems that the Wouter's
team tried to solve.
And that some of
these will inspire you
on how you can
combine the services
we have to provide the
solution that works for you.
And at this point, we
are very happy to take
any questions you may have.
We ended up being a little
bit faster than we expected.
So lots of questions.
And I have some stickers
if anyone wants.
Only for the ones
who ask questions.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
JELENA PJESIVAC-GRBOVIC:
You want to repeat?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
The question was, do you have,
on top of the technical stack
itself, big [INAUDIBLE].
Do you have these
business scenarios or use
cases somehow captured into,
say, templatized formats,
like certain business cases or
specific types of use cases?
JELENA PJESIVAC-GRBOVIC:
We do have
a couple of things for this.
On cloud.google.com/bigdata,
there are templated examples
of different business use cases.
I think we have six or nine.
I know there are three
a column, but I don't
know how many rows we have.
All of them have
a code in GitHub,
so you can actually see
how the code looks like.
And many of them are integration
between the different products,
because it's like
in a big data space.
We also have a ton
of datasets that
are available through
BigQuery or on GCS
that you can use
to sort of explore
the ideas that you have.
So yeah, so there is some
documentation and some
of the examples there.
We also offer some
trainings for these things.
And I believe if you
are interested in that,
I can find more information.
I don't know it
on top of my head.
But we definitely
continually build
this database of the
white papers and examples.
And I think very recently we
had a-- like I think this week,
or Friday last week, we
had a publication by one
of our SMEs, Subject
Matter Experts, [INAUDIBLE]
on the best practices when
using the big data tools.
And that will be ongoing series.
So he published the
first part last week.
AUDIENCE: So thanks
for your presentation.
It may be a question for Wouter.
How do you deal with personally
identifiable information that
comes from your
website in regards
to the nature of Bigtable, which
stores every record and also
every mutation of every
record, especially now
with GDPR coming up?
So my question is very general.
How do you deal with that?
WOUTER CUYPERS: It's
a very good question.
And we've thought
about it a lot.
What Cloud Platform really
allows you to do really well
is set permissions on
a technology level.
So each service, you can
keep it away from people.
You can use specific
service accounts.
So we don't want any analysts
talking to our Bigtable.
We also don't want
any other developers
talking to our Bigtable,
or other microservices.
We keep that inside
our own team.
And we get to say what we export
to the databases that allow
them to generate reporting.
Because they can't use Bigtable.
They can only use
Cloud SQL, or BigQuery.
So there we can use
separate tables.
So that's a bit the idea
that we're going to use.
We're going to put all of
the information that's really
personally identifiable
in different tables,
and they would need
to join it together
to know who it really is.
And only some people, like in
customer care, can do that.
It will be done in
their back office.
They will get the
rights to do that,
but most people
will not be able to.
Because you don't need
to know that information
to do most of your work anyway.
Is that kind of an
answer to your question?
AUDIENCE: It is, but then I
have a question for Jelena.
JELENA PJESIVAC-GRBOVIC: OK.
AUDIENCE: Thanks again.
So is there-- can you
specify in Bigtable
the type of retention period?
So the GDPR specifies
that some type of data you
will have to delete in maybe
two years or five years,
depending on the type of data.
Can you set a retention
period, or is that
a thing you have to add a
little process in your flow
to take care of that?
JELENA PJESIVAC-GRBOVIC: So
that's an excellent question.
So do we have capabilities to
automatically remove the data
after certain period of time?
And I would have to look up what
at Bigtable exactly it sets.
I know we do have these supports
for these things, for example,
in Dataflow.
And we have services
for this in Google.
So you register, and if
the information is deleted,
you have to yank it
out of your system.
So specifically for
Bigtable, I don't know,
but I can look it up.
But we definitely
care about the data,
and will are very well
aware of the data policies.
So it's something we care about.
WOUTER CUYPERS:
But on the GDPR, we
are currently working
with consultants
who are specialized
in this, and even they
don't know how it's going to be.
So it's going to be
with the EU cookie law.
Some big players are going
to make the first moves,
and the rest will kind
of standardize on that.
And it's also not
that clear cut.
You don't have to delete
the data, they tell us.
You have to anonymize it.
So you have to delete someone's
name and email address,
but you can still
keep views and orders.
And some data you will even
need to keep, like an invoice.
You will need to
keep that forever
in your database, which
is also personally
identifiable information.
So it's much more
complicated than that.
AUDIENCE: It's true, while
being in a big player,
we tend to be the [INAUDIBLE].
WOUTER CUYPERS: For you.
JELENA PJESIVAC-GRBOVIC:
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, OK.
So my question is for Wouter.
I was listening to
your presentation
and I think it's nice, but
what for me was missing
was that I want to believe
that this journey has not
been all roses.
And if there has
been any hurdles
that you've encountered
in this process
that you want to
share that would
be as an example for anybody who
wants to be on this migration
journey.
WOUTER CUYPERS: I think
one of the main hurdles,
if you see what kind of
evolution we went through,
is getting to grips with the
different breeds of technology
that Google has.
Bigtable is really a very
different kind of database
than an SQL database.
And if you look at it,
it looks as if you simply
can't do much with Bigtable.
You read rows, you scan
rows, and you write them.
And that's it.
But their schema design is
absolutely essential for what
you want to do.
So you need to spend more time
thinking about such things.
And there's also
a lot of mistakes
that you make,
beginner mistakes.
The first dataflows
that we wrote, yeah,
that didn't go over roses.
We needed to get to grips
with the technology.
So you need to invest a
lot of time in learning.
And I hope your company
allows you to do that,
because you will spend some
time trying things out.
JELENA PJESIVAC-GRBOVIC:
But presumably, it's
worth it, right?
WOUTER CUYPERS: Absolutely.
JELENA PJESIVAC-GRBOVIC:
OK, there is a question.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
Wouter, thank you for
your presentation.
How big is your team which
thought this through and build
the implementations?
WOUTER CUYPERS: The
complete IT department
is between 40 and 50 people.
I don't know exactly.
And my department is
just seven people.
But I think there
were some key people
in there, our architects, like
Alex, who's here's up front.
It's his brainchild that
I'm presenting here.
So he did a marvelous job.
So if you want to congratulate
him or ask him more in-depth
questions, he's actually one
of the only Google development
experts in Belgium--
or the only one for Cloud.
AUDIENCE: Not any more.
WOUTER CUYPERS: Not any more?
And he works for us.
We're very happy with that.
AUDIENCE: That helps a lot.
WOUTER CUYPERS: It does.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: Question for Wouter.
Why and how did you
choose Google Cloud?
What was the decision tree?
WOUTER CUYPERS:
Very good question.
Now, as you've seen,
we're not a big company.
We're not a bank.
We're not a big retailer.
And when I came
into the company,
we were only like 90 people.
We're three times that.
So it was a 20 people IT team.
And yeah, two guys taking
care of a little bit of BI.
So we had no time or
resources to compare
20 different providers,
technologies, and whatnot.
So the decision was
based on a few things.
One of them was we had a very
good relationship with Google
because we were a
top AdWords client.
We've got people with
a lot of experience
with Google
technology, like Alex.
But I think one of
the main reasons
was that Google has these
technologies that Jelena
has been showing us.
Things like BigQuery.
I mean, three years ago we
were baffled by the power
that thing has.
And this pushed
us over the edge.
And also, the fact
that everything
can be done in a managed way.
I mean, you can run
Redshift, you can run Kafka.
But you still have to
do a lot of management
of all of the servers that
run below these things.
And we simply do not have
the resources to do that.
If we need to do that ourselves,
it will take us two years just
to build the infrastructure.
So that was one of
the key reasons for us
to do it like this, because
with a very small team,
we can do really powerful stuff.
JELENA PJESIVAC-GRBOVIC:
Any other questions?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
WOUTER CUYPERS: I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: Can you use--
JELENA PJESIVAC-GRBOVIC:
Can you use the mic?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
JELENA PJESIVAC-GRBOVIC:
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Did you make use of
a Google [INAUDIBLE] or was it
completely your team that--
WOUTER CUYPERS: For this, not.
Though for the
original architecture,
we did kind of--
well, the first steps
into BigQuery two years
ago, we talked a little bit
to Datatonic, who's
here and has a booth.
And I think went into Cloud
Data Platform because of us.
So we had some chats
straight in the beginning
to confirm some of the big
bets that we were taking.
But that's about it.
The rest is made inhouse.
JELENA PJESIVAC-GRBOVIC:
OK, well
thank you everyone for coming.
And you can grab us after this.
[APPLAUSE]